cue the music It's the final countdown
you better get clearance for that truly
we can't run any more than that so I
think I think that melody was so off I
don't even think you infringe on the
copyright there we go no lawsuits Over
Here Blake how are you feeling heading
into the final shows I feel good I'm
excited I'm I'm uh
I'm in a good place about this you know
I don't have any regrets about it I'm
definitely going to miss it uh at times
but uh it's time I mean my gosh you know
I saw a little uh blurb the other day
somebody caught Adam Levine and going
into a party somewhere and they said
what do you think about Blake leaving
and he turned around he said it's about
time you know so that was our interview
how was it really sorry
hey Adam what about Blake leaving The
Voice man
well uh he's right it is about time you
know I've done it forever and uh this
has changed my life you know in in a lot
of ways
uh but you know it's time to to let one
of these these new up and coming artists
become a coach like Reba like that would
be a good break up in Commerce yeah it'd
be a good break for her fresh face on TV
she needs it she finally needs a big
break in in her life you know it's so
wild is
back come on the show they're gonna need
to fill that
who could fill Blake's shoes from from
an alcohol standpoint she's right I mean
I hold that I hold that Championship
deer to my heart you know as nobody has
drank as much as I have on this show
yeah got the the proof the video proof
of it that's right how do you feel about
Reba coming into the voice family I feel
like especially you know taking your
chairs well I feel like no one no one
better than Reba right no one better
than Reba honestly and to be honest I'm
and I don't mean this as a as a as a dig
to anybody I'm shocked that they got her
I mean Reba's an icon it's getting her
to even be a mentor on this show I was
going whoa I mean again she's she's
doing this again like
there's been a handful of of artists
over the years like Dolly and we had
Bette Midler we've had Taylor Swift you
know and Reba is one of those to me
that's like oh my God we got Reba rebas
coming in even though I know her uh on a
on a friendship level I've never gotten
away from that she's one of my heroes
You Know Reba was one of the reasons I
even moved to Nashville she was from
Oklahoma from a small middle of nowhere
town and and made it you know and so she
was my inspiration and and so I always
see her in that light you know so it's
he gonna get better to represent country
music than than Reba I mean if it's not
you
okay you've got a drink though Reba now
of her wife Gwen Stefani I feel like
your household someone's got to be a
part of the voice here now oh are you
gonna have a little fomo with her coming
back will you be watching on TV being
like totally fine
uh
yeah oh get it boy
probably not
uh I mean this is there's not a moment
of this show that when I see it on TV
that I and this is when I know that it's
time for me to get out of here it's like
oh I know I know what happened with that
light over there because I've seen it
like fall a few times and oh I know what
hallway that is because that's where you
know we get in like I just know I
it's like
I know too much now at this point you
know what I'm saying so it's a hard no
of you coming back as a mentor I need to
have a chance forever holy
wow look at it
chance said that he will win this season
come on man let oh cause the camera's on
I get it come on let him get one wildly
inappropriate
exactly he's acting weird just because
I'll catch you later yeah he said he was
going to take home the win this season
just say well he's been lying since he
got here
[Music]